and your plane tickets
you can tell the immigration officer that you have a right to call your attorney
so remember these things and explain your rights
the only primary documents you need to present before the immigration
who will ask you irrelevant and unreasonable documents like a yearbook
Na lang pwedeng ma offload ang passengers and travelers
Hey Attorney!
the reason why it can be strict in the immigration is because of Ra 9208
If ma-hold ako sa immigration ng ilang oras
if there are inconsistencies found in these documents
if you're being questioned unreasonably or
but that doesn't mean basta basta
na offload ka
that RA 9208 should not restrict the right to travel
what should I do?
what do I tell the immigration officers?
explain to them calmly that you have a right to travel according to Section 6
visa if applicable
or the Anti Trafficking in Persons Act of 2003
without any valid basis or kahit kumpleto yung mga documents mo
if you're being held in their office being accused of a crime or
second if they want to offload you or ayaw ka nilang paliparin
because even the law states in Section 30
this is guaranteed by the Constitution
what if they want to offload me
doon palang hahanapin yung secondary documents like hotel accommodations
watch out for abusive immigration officers
as long as the purpose for travel is lawful
or ask you to open your Facebook messenger so that they could read the messages
Article 3 of the 1987 Constitution
first
are passport
itinerary bank statements and the like